le
458 c'est monsieur kzic qui le défend
merci madame la Présidente le
gouvernement a promis de raboter les
niches fiscales pourtant force de
constater qu'elle n qu'elle continue de
grossir moi je voudrais revenir sur la
la niche dite niche Copé qui permet une
exonération partielle d'impôts sur les
plus-values à long terme sur la session
de filiale et de titre
participation cette exonération
bénéficie massivement au holding
facilitant ainsi l'optimisation fiscale
pour par fait un célèbre proverbe
nordiste cher au président canner il
paraît quand c'est flou c'est qu'il y a
un loup et disons-le l'évaluation du
coût total de la niche Copé n'apparaît
absolument pas claire les documents que
vous avez transmis au Parlement monsieur
le ministre ne permett pas d'y voir plus
clair en 2019 l'estimation d'un coû
annuel de 5 milliards d'euros a pu être
avancé par le président de la commission
des finances de l'Assemblée nationale
donc j'en appelle donc un peu de
cohérence vous souhaitez réaliser près
de 10 milliards d'euros d'économie sur
le quinquena en luttant contre la fraude
et en supprimant les niches fiscales et
sociale par cet amendement nous vous y
aidons alègrement je pense que par
ailleurs cela serait beaucoup plus
pertinent que la proposition qui a été
faite hier par le de mémoire par le
président de laa qui proposer de de de
supprimer un certain nombre de de niches
j'ai noté la location logement la
loocation personnalisée du logement les
prestations familiales ainsi que la
location
adulte handicapé je pense que ce serait
plus pertinent de revenir sur laanich
Copé par ailleurs il est inutile de de
mettre en place comme ça a été fait à
l'Assemblée une Task Force qui a mis qui
a pour mission de faire des propositions
moi je crois que j'ai une très belle
proposition avec le groupe socialiste et
nous vous épargnons avec la suppression
des task forces inutiles et donc je vous
invite à voter cette suppression de la
niche Copé qui vise à tenir compte de la
baisse du taux d'imposition sur les
sociétés
merci